[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I alone can fix it
July 21st 2016 at the Republican
convention in Cleveland the five Trump
words that officially proclaimed his bid
to overthrow the traditional government
of the United States of America and
replace it with him as I have argued
here this week you can look at the first
60 plus days of his presidency as a
succession of losses and incompetence
and humiliations that would have said
almost any other human being who found
himself in Trump's choose fleeing for
the Cayman Islands but one comment by
one woman with the improbable name of
Sharla makka makka as me wondering if
this this chaos monger this
embarrassment this petulant little boy
refusing to shake Angela Merkel's and
this doer of this latest stuff he did
just today this imbecile in imbeciles
clothing it has me wondering if all this
is actually the plan I alone can fix it
Charla Mikami
M little C capital C om I see is the
woman from Lexington Tennessee whom
Jenna Johnson of the Washington Post
found MS McComb ik is 52 years old her
son lost his job and yet his health
insurance premium dropped from 567
dollars a month to 88 dollars a month
quote a blessing from God unquote said
Miss McCormack a blessing from God via
Donald Trump quoting her again I think
it was just because of the tax credit
that's the Trump Ryan Republican plan to
impart replace the Affordable Care Act
with a series of tax credits she thinks
her son's insurance premium plummeted
because of the Trump plan that has not
even been passed by the House and the
Senate
let alone become law yet she thinks
Trump did this for her in fact Obama did
this for her her son's insurance premium
dropped 479 dollars a month due to
Obamacare but not in her mind no Trump
brought her God's blessing I alone can
fix it do you remember that massive
numbers of Iraqis this is in
21st century mind you massive numbers of
Iraqis believe that Saddam Hussein were
a magical stone around his neck where he
had had one implanted in his arm that
made him invulnerable to attack and that
if somehow he was killed Kaos would
consume Iraq I alone can fix it
have you watched Turkey in the last year
a country riven with terrorism and
sectarianism coming apart at the seams
and then this lunatic bully erawan who
some believe either fomented a coup
against his own government which
included insurgents who just happened to
not shoot down the plane he was in while
they were next to it or if it wasn't a
false flag he just happened to be in
position to almost immediately exploit
it to detain arrest or dismiss from
their jobs as many as 150,000 of his own
citizens and then put the blame on a
dissident living in Pennsylvania and
then put to a national vote his bid to
eliminate the remnants of Turkish
democracy and place all power in his own
hands I alone can fix it I'm a Leninist
Steve Bannon reportedly told a reporter
from The Daily Beast in a 2013
conversation he now claims he does not
remember Lenin wanted to destroy the
state and that's my goal too I want to
bring everything crashing down and
destroy all of today's establishment
thus I alone can fix it would actually
just be shorthand for a longer quote I
alone can fix it after so many of you
never noticed that I alone broke it mind
you I'm not convinced of this
most of the fascists who have popped up
seized power in this country's history
have been pretty easy to analyze the
question I am the hell are they doing
this this way does not usually come with
a series of multiple-choice fascist
answers I'm still not convinced Trump
and his cronies are not just morons who
have tried to apply the simple rules
that always work for them in bully
corporate ownership through the mega
complexity of geopolitics I'm still not
convinced they're not all crazy I'm
still not convinced they're not all
stoned they sure act
stoned but what if this is the plan
claimed the British tapped his phones
threatened North Korea and China insult
the German Chancellor try to bring her
into his own paranoid wiretapping Oakes
quote a bozo from Fox about it turn
around and throw the bozo from Fox under
the bus blame the rest of the news media
for painting the Merkel meeting is bad
and himself paint Merkel as some kind of
deadbeat and all of that in a span of
just 24 hours what would all that mean
to miss Sharla God's blessing my comic
of Lexington Tennessee why it would mean
her president is under attack by the
British by the Germans by the North
Koreans by the Chinese by Obama by fake
news by Fox News by the judges by the
Democrats by the paid protesters by the
Muslims by the Hispanics by the
non-christians I alone can fix it and
when it's broken what matter who is
really at fault to charlo makka makka
when some atrocity from this medieval
budget gets through when say the Delta
Regional Authority and to similar
agencies that Trump wants to get cut get
cut the agencies that fix the roads and
the sewers and fund the health clinics
and support the local small businesses
in 698 rural counties including in
Charla mechanics Tennessee 698 rural
counties Trump won by 26% what happens
when the Delta Regional Authority goes
away cut from the budget Trump blame
somebody else
and Cheryl I'm a comic blames somebody
else the Democrats did it the
Republicans did it the career
politicians did it when they altered
trump's blessed budget but it never
worked though of course not he could
never get away with being president I
didn't do it and he could never pitch
for nearly three weeks a hoax that
Barack Obama tapped his phones or
insists that that story was reported in
the New York Times or that he used quote
marks on his tweets about it when half
his tweets had no quote marks or claimed
that he disapproved birtherism
or insist that the generals lost the
Navy Seal in Yemen or contend that the
judiciary had no right to interfere with
his idea of legal and illegal travel
bans or his idea of what is safe and
what is terroristic and he can never get
people thinking the way they thought in
Iraq or the way they're thinking now in
Turkey he could never get Cheryl I'm a
comic to convince herself by herself
that her son's insurance dropped four
hundred seventy nine bucks a month not
due to Obamacare but due to trumped tax
credits that don't exist yet and even if
she did start thinking that way so what
she's obviously on the fringes of
society she's not very bright
she's not very she's a retired
schoolteacher Cheryl I'm a comic and her
friends by the way campaigned for Trump
started a motorcade shouting his name
and passers-by as they did quote we said
who else would we do this for besides
Trump we agreed on the lord we would
stand here for the Lord but that's about
it
so what happens if my comics son now
actually loses his insurance because of
Trump and Ryan and the Republicans
presumably all Trump would have to do is
blame somebody else anybody she already
believes him he could probably convince
her he has a magic stone under his skin
but if all this is the plan
maybe that stone is for later maybe
that's for when there is a real crisis
that Trump has fostered and he ignores
the courts or the Congress or the
Constitution about it and blames
somebody else for all of it right now
the only thing he has to do is just say
it again to her I alone can fix it after
so many of you never noticed that I
alone broke it resist peace